[Music]
they've been drinking in this brewery
for more than four centuries this
building has known kings dictators and
democracy and here surrounded by history
we found german voters who wanted out
with the old and in with something new
many people are going to be excited and
it's going to be very important for many
people to go and vote
in order to
make
their voice heard
i think we need a lot of change because
the last 16 years
although a lot of things happened
nothing really really changed the
culture the way we would need it in the
next years
nearby a final round of drinks for the
present chancellor
angela merkel has almost called time on
her leadership the pressure now is on
the man in the blue suit armin lashed
her successor as head of the cdu party
once the clear favorite to win the
election comfortably now hoping to avoid
an embarrassing defeat
after 16 years at the forefront of
german and global public life angela
merkel's tenure is coming to an end and
she's here to try to sprinkle some
much-needed stardust on her party
stuttering campaign
this election is entering its final
nervous stages and it's too close to
call there was no knockout moment in the
final televised debate featuring
lashette the social democrat olaf
schultz and the woman who could yet
disrupt this election
annalina berbock leader of the greens at
this rally in potsdam she got
endorsements from a pop star and took
the chance to say that her party isn't
just about climate change
[Music]
but climate is a big part of this
election in berlin and across germany
thousands protested today
we must vote you must vote we want
change
we demand change
and we are the change
in the shadow of the german parliament
climate change activists staged hunger
strikes they've been largely ignored
lena didn't eat for 20 days she's angry
with politicians from all parties
if they don't even want to talk the
truth about climate crisis they don't
even fight against them so i think none
of the politicians do enough against the
climate crisis what about baba
she is the greens yeah yes she's the
greens but she don't even do enough
against the climate crisis back in
bavaria the music and the beer are
flowing
with hours to go germany still feels
undecided
adam parsons sky news munich